في جميع أنحاء الولايات المتحدة ،
تستمر الرغبة في الحصول على اللقاح 19 في خفض
المعدل اليومي للجرعات التي تم الإبلاغ عن
إعطائها بنسبة 20 في المائة عن الأسبوع الماضي
، ويعمل كبار مسؤولي الصحة الأمريكيين على
تحقيق
هدف الحصول على 70 في المائة من الأمريكيين
جرعة واحدة على الأقل بحلول يوليو
رابعًا ، أعتقد أننا سنكون قادرين على القيام
بذلك وأعتقد أنه من خلال تغيير
قليل من الإستراتيجية
وفي الوقت نفسه ، هناك المزيد من الأدلة على أن الناس لا
يحتاجون فقط إلى جرعتين كاملتين من اللقاح
ولكن قد يحتاجون في النهاية إلى جرعة ثالثة
لتعزيز المناعة.  توقع أن
الأشخاص الذين تم تحصينهم أيضًا في مرحلة ما سيكون
لديهم
استجابات مناعية متضائلة ويحتاجون إلى
معززات
وفقًا لكبير المسؤولين
الطبيين بشركة Pfizer ، تُظهر أحدث البيانات أن
لقاح covit 19 التابع للشركة
لا يزال 90 فعالاً في الوقاية من
أعراض المرض
بعد ستة أشهر من التطعيم الكامل
، سنستمر في
رصد هذا من أجل الحصول على
فهم
حول متى وعدد المرات التي تكون فيها المعززات
مطلوبة.
لقاح الفيروس التاجي الخاص به
يرفع من الاستجابة المناعية ضد نوعين مقلقين
، جرعة معززة تم صياغتها خصيصًا
لتتناسب مع البديل الذي شوهد لأول مرة في جنوب
إفريقيا ،
وكانت أكثر فاعلية في اللحظات الصحية.